For many people, you know, spending time
in a dreamy location looks like this.
But for me it looks like this.
(Laughter)
As a natural product chemist,
I have always been inspired
by those wonderful chemical substances
we found in nature,
especially the chemicals
that are made by living organisms
from cold environments.
And today, I want to bring you along
on my incredible journey
into discovering the molecular treasure
hiding in plants and other organisms
thriving in the cold.
OK. Now I know what you might be thinking.
"Norman, this just isn't for me.
Chemistry was my worst subject in school,
and I hate being cold.
Why on Earth should I keep listening?”
(Laughter)
To which I say,
stay with me.
Because I’m convinced
that there’s some amazing chemicals
hiding in the north,
which perhaps means
that the next wonder drug
to treat some of the nasty diseases
that plague us humans
is just waiting to be discovered.
But we might not discover it
without your help.
Are you intrigued now?
(Audience) Yes!
Good. But before we go on
with the chemistry,
I want to give you
a quick geography lesson.
When we talk about the Canadian north,
we talk about the land
which is north of the 55th parallel.
This includes most of the parts
of Nunavik and Nunavut.
And this land is really famous
for beautiful landscape.
It's famous for polar bears.
It's famous for northern lights
and it’s famous for ...
Santa Claus.
(Laughter)
But despite these famous icons,
the great white snowy North
is still largely unexplored.
And that's especially true
at the molecular level.
And my team and I hypothesize
that the northern ecosystem
must be producing
fantastic unknown chemicals
with fascinating properties.
Why?
Because of the harsh conditions
and the unique stresses
plants, fungi and other organism
are experiencing in the north.
They must produce chemicals
to protect themselves from these stresses.
For example, imagine
the sunburn you would get
sunbathing for over 20 hours
a day for a month.
Well, to survive, you would need
a tremendously good sunscreen.
That's exactly what lichens have
in the northern ecosystem.
To protect themselves from UV radiation,
they fabricate a defense chemical
that blocks UV rays
with an outstanding efficiency.
And that's only one
of the defense chemicals we know about.
And we believe
that there are many, many more
hiding up there.
A couple of years ago, my group and I
began our endeavors to prove this.
Now, let me bring you to Umiujaq, Nunavik,
a small Inuit village
on the coast of the Hudson Bay.
And we were interested there,
we collected and we looked
at the grayish lichens
that have been very scarcely investigated,
Stereocaulon paschale.
Now this lichen
is found only in ecosystems
with very harsh climate conditions.
And almost nothing was known at that time
on its chemical content.
So we thought it was
a great species to investigate.
So even though Stereocaulon paschale
is quite abundant in Nunavik,
we always try to minimize our footprint.
So we sampled only 100 gram of the lichens
and we brought it back to our lab
at Université Laval in Quebec City.
There we cleaned it and then we crushed it
at -190 degree Celsius,
using liquid nitrogen.
And this step is essential
to release the natural substances
within the lichen cell.
We then transformed the sample
in the form of pulp
using different solvents
in a process called maceration.
And after we filtered the sample
and evaporated the solvents,
we obtained what we call
a crude lichen extract.
And for a natural product chemist,
that's when the fun starts.
(Laughter)
Through careful chromatographic separation
and many other techniques,
and years of work,
we've been able to separate, purify
and identify for the first time ever
13 natural substances
in Stereocaulon paschale.
Now, I know, your minds
are exploding right now.
(Laughter)
But wait, there's more.
From these 13 natural substances,
turned out that 11 had already been
identified in other lichens,
but two of the substances
turned out to be unique in the world.
Think about it for a moment.
From over 340,000
natural chemical substances
known on the planet,
Stereocaulon paschale from Nunavik
is producing two unique substances,
a clear demonstration
that organisms experiencing stresses
in the northern ecosystem
produce unique chemicals.
Now what are the properties
of these chemicals,
of these natural substances?
We don't know at this point.
This is still under investigation.
And to me, and I hope to you now,
this is the exciting part.
Who knows if the next generation
of much needed anti-inflammatory agent
or cancer fighting drug
or even cure for Alzheimer
will be inspired by a chemical substance
from Nunavik lichens.
Wow.
Let me bring you now further north.
In Nunavut,
on the beautiful Baffin Island.
And here the story began
when a group of Canadian microbiologists
identified for the first time ever
in the sediment of the beautiful,
cold Frobisher Bay,
a microscopic fungus.
Well, the fungus was part of the genus
of what we call Mortierella.
And so they called it,
with not much originality,
Mortierella species.
(Laughter)
But they also discovered
that this weird-looking fungus
is synthesizing unique
natural substances, mortiamides.
Now why a rather strange-looking fungus
is producing these natural substances
is still a mystery.
However, this sparked our curiosity.
From past research investigation,
we knew that natural substances
that share some of the similarities
with the mortiamide,
compounds isolated
from the jatropha plants from Africa
had antimalaria properties
because they were able to neutralize
the parasite responsible
for the majority of malaria cases.
Could the mortiamides
possess the same properties?
Well, to find out,
we went back into the lab
and we synthesized sufficient quantity
of all the mortiamides.
And we studied
their antimalarial activity.
And guess what?
One of the substances, the mortiamide D,
efficiently neutralized
the parasite of malaria.
But that's not the end of the story.
It's even better.
It was able to neutralize
a strain of the parasite
that is resistant to many, many
malaria drugs currently use in clinics.
Isn't that amazing?
You get the natural substances
coming out from,
produced by a microscopic fungus
isolated from the sediment
of the icy cold Frobisher Bay
in the great white, snowy north
that could provide an answer to one
of the most terrible tropical infections.
It's a small world after all.
(Laughter)
Isn't it?
(Audience) Yes!
Well, it's time to talk
about the scary news.
The north, unfortunately, is undergoing
transformation at an alarming pace.
It is warming up faster
than anywhere else on the planet.
And this leads to a phenomenon called
the greening of the northern ecosystem.
And this is particularly
true with Nunavik.
There's a shrub called Betula glandulosa
that is progressing north very rapidly.
Now one of the immediate consequences
of this rapid shrub growth
is that it decreases the daylight
on the lower plants and lichen.
This is altering the complete food chain,
and it’s altering also the traditional way
of living of the Indigenous community.
And, unavoidably, this will lead
to loss of biodiversity.
And one of the hidden consequences
of losing biodiversity
is the loss of chemodiversity.
It is my great fear that with the loss
of plants, lichen and fungi,
some unknown, fascinating
natural substances
and potentially wonder drugs
could be lost, too.
Now,
this is why we think
our work is important.
And timely.
And this is why
I hope by now you're convinced
that you have a good reason to help
protect the great white, snowy north.
For my part,
I'm going to continue to search
for molecular treasures in the north
in the hope of finding novel arguments
to provide stakeholders and politicians
with good arguments
for enforcing stronger and immediate
measures to mitigate climate change.
For your part, remember
the story of mortiamide D,
and how a discovery in the north
could save lives in the tropics?
We're all in this together.
And no matter what corner
of the planet you lived in,
you must do your part to save Mother Earth
one molecule at the time.
Merci beaucoup. Thank you.
(Applause)